I've said many times that whether Donald
Trump is personally racist is not the
most important aspect of how Trump's
administration will deal with the
reality that the United States is not
just white people who Trump emboldened
as well as who Trump hires are going to
be major factors we know that Trump is
hugely emboldened white supremacists and
white nationalists they love they
celebrate not only Trump but the
appointment of for example Steve Bannon
to be one of Trump's closest advisors as
I told you last week over the weekend we
learned that Donald Trump is actually
building out a team of deplorable --zz
many are saying this is just these are
this is racist after racist we know
about Steve ban and already Breitbart
news CEO didn't want his daughters going
to a school with too many Jews and after
all he did run Breitbart which has
promoted the alt-right Breitbart itself
has an article published which defines
the alt-right as a slightly more
intelligent version of skinheads
we now have learned about janitor septa
Senator Jeff Sessions from Alabama who
is the Attorney General choice we've
learned about former Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn the national security
adviser we've learned about Congressman
Mike Pompeo head of the CIA shortly
after the Flynn and sessions pics were
announced former KKK leader David Duke
celebrated on Twitter actually saying as
I will show you here Bannen Flynn and
sessions Americans are on their way to
taking back our government our nation
and our children's future the background
on Jeff sessions is he suggested a white
lawyer might be a disgrace to his race
because he represented black clients he
referred to the 1965 Voting Rights Act
as a piece of intrusive legislation he
was deemed too racist to be a federal
judge and he is going to be Donald
Attorney General he also once remarked
that he thought the KKK wasn't bad until
he found out that they smoked marijuana
also his views on marijuana deeply
disturbing here is a quote from Jeff
Sessions at some drug hearings in April
this drug is dangerous you cannot play
with it it is not funny it's not
something to laugh about and to send
that message with clarity that good
people don't smoke marijuana
in 2016 the Attorney General is going to
hold the view I guess in 2017 that if
you smoke pot you fundamentally cannot
be a good person then we've got Michael
Flynn who has repeatedly made it clear
that he draws no distinction between
Isis and Islam in general even george w
bush went through the effort to at least
make it seem like he was distinguishing
between radical Islam and other Muslims
but with Flynn it's not even only about
his outrageous views he is paid by
authoritarian regimes in Turkey and
Russia as well as Russia's propaganda
apparatus multiple figures who have
worked with Flynn described him as
unhinged and then we get to Congressman
Mike Pompeo who was advocated for the
killing of Edward Snowden quote from a
c-span interview earlier this year
Pompeyo said he should be brought back
from Russia and given due process and I
think that the proper outcome would be
that he would be given a death sentence
for having put friends of mine friends
of yours in the military today at
enormous risk because of the information
he stole and then released to foreign
powers these are true deplorable and I'm
alternating pat between laughing and
crying because of all those people who
said you know Hillary and Trump are
gonna be the same and I'm not gonna vote
they're the same thing and more than
roughly half of the country stayed home
there is no similarity here and we've
been saying this for a long time well
the thing is at least sessions and
Pompeyo will have congressional hearings
before they're ultimately put through to
the Asians not Flint but in terms of
advisers they don't need any sort of
public hearing you know we had all of
these Trump supporters who said you know
Trump's gonna be great for free speech
and the open Internet yet Trump is
against net neutrality without even
knowing much about it they said oh he's
gonna stop government from getting
involved in people's lives through
spying and surveillance yet he picked
Mike Pompeo to run the CIA who wants to
expand surveillance and he said people
would say Oh Trump he's not into the
whole war on drugs he's selecting an
attorney general who thinks if you smoke
pot you fundamentally can't be a good
person the Trump errs the trumpet's as
we're now calling them they took the
bait and he is going to do damage to the
country